there is this theory I'm just wondering
where you fall in his theory what you
believe people some people think that
Trump doesn't like the job he had a
great a better life before he didn't
expect to win he has one now and that he
might be looking for a way out because
it's been nothing but headaches where do
you what do you think is that is that a
possibility that's my theory
that is your goal that yeah that's my
theory I kept come on can you imagine
you are a billionaire allegedly we
haven't seen the tax returns you're a
billionaire a multi billionaire you live
in a tower on Fifth Avenue in New York
City you have a beautiful wife you have
a plane you have you golf courses in
houses you can go wherever you want and
you're a free person you can tweet and
say whatever you want criticize everyone
call the other president you know not
American born in Africa you can do
whatever you want with compute complete
impunity right right but then now you
can you are under investigation your
campaign people may end up going to jail
the people are talking about impeachment
I think although I think we're you know
that seems that's a long way sure it's a
long way off but imagine that and you
can't do that I don't think he likes a
job I think that he will find a way to
get out of it at some point it's a lot
of work to be and and and pretty much
every president has said the same thing
which is it's a great deal of work we
all saw Obama age it looked like it you
know 20 years in an eight-year span it
is an incredibly difficult job it is a
difficult job but I mean he said it
would be easy remember he said I'm gonna
world peace basically it was like a
beauty pageant contestant on one of his
right I'm gonna have world peace and
it's gonna be so easy but you know or
health care who knew health care would
be so hard yeah most of the people yeah
so so done let's say your dream came
true and you were able to interview
President Trump that would be a good
interview for you what would your
question be for him I would want to know
what level spray-tan is it
[Laughter]
is it cheeto orange or is it like
Orangina or you know the Orange Crush
yeah yeah we that certain that it's it's
gotta be a spray tan come on he's not in
the Sun I mean look do you go in the Sun
he's kind of not allowed in the Sun well
he's I don't think he's allowed to sunny
I'm getting I'm getting moon burn right
you have to be jealous of how orange or
sort of brown I had stupid hair and a
fat head long before he did and he took
it he took it took my whole hey your
hair dude I was a one named guy with big
goofy hair and a fat head and then he
stole who talked too much and he stuffed
my act that was my act I would also want
to know if he believes this [ __ ] that
comes out of his mouth as well if you're
gonna swear I'm gonna ask you to take
your skateboard and go please no
you